what's up man we're here this is awesome
it's my first interview on Instagram
live we got it man I was just talking
about you being the mindset King man
I've never been referred to as that but
I'll take it
this is it people's habits they're stuck
in cruise control a lot we just play
small by default we stay in
procrastination land how do you attach
it the mindset King Garon Jones like how
do we catch it how do we get out of our
cruise control get out of this autopilot
and go off to a greater life well
honestly you you can't see a picture
while you're in the frame so most people
who are on cruise control it's like it's
like cemeteries not where you see the
most dead people it's like we walk
around outside everyday you see people
with something that died inside of them
and the worst part about it is they
don't even know it so they're just kind
of just existing in that life not really
living and you can't change what you're
not aware of
so it takes some kind of sign or some
kind of something to wake you up to to
wake you up to what you're even doing
cuz most people have no clue and I've
spoken to thousands of people all over
the world they have no clue of what
they're doing or why they're doing what
they're doing because it's kind of been
ingrained inside of them since their
childhood they do with their mom or dad
does where their teacher does or society
does until something happens one day
they wake up they're like damn I didn't
even realize it so I think the biggest
thing is by even you having a platform
like this first and foremost thank you
for having a platform like this and
welcoming voices like mine to actually
be heard so people can hear the truth
for for for once in their life so you
can lie too I think's at the beginning
of mankind so definitely thank you for
that but honestly it's like whenever we
have the opportunity to create that
awareness for people and something that
they actually relate to now I'm not
talking about you give precalculus to a
baby and they don't understand
I'm talking about when you have content
and a platform and there's somebody with
a voice or there's a book that people
can actually read and not have to
decipher codes or anything like that so
that they can understand what they're in
I honestly feel that's the only way to
get someone's attention is by showing
like them who like who they are really
and hitting them in a way was like holy
like I didn't even realize that I was in
side of this it's like me I was broke
broke mindset literally my whole entire
life I didn't know that I thought
everybody was broke I thought
everybody's lights went off and your
parents had to light up candles I didn't
know that there was like wealthy people
in the world so I wasn't like I didn't
know until I saw the difference and I
started being around different people
I'm like yo why does this person have a
car and why do I not have a car how come
I key I'm getting free lunch and how
come this guy has money you know so I
never knew that until I was aware of
something else when I was aware of
something else then I had the
opportunity to choose but then once I
start feeling lonely and feeling
doubtful and feeling insecure but I saw
somebody that was feeling confident and
they had money and they were happy I was
like that's what I want that that's what
I want so it's just about providing
awareness for people to know what's
possible outside of their condition
programming that's what I'm doing I know
that's what you're doing with everything
that you're up to for that for people
who are who are watching how do they
force it on themselves daily right like
they might be watching this and get
inspired like I'm gonna I'm gonna take
life by the reins I'm going for but then
the next day they wake up and it's all
you know back to square one
how do you how do you take control
yourself daily when a lot of these
things might be external influences on
you I take it like this take a little
kid who listens to a song over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over what is the little kid doing
for the next month with that song
singing it humming it doing the dance
over and over and over because he's
literally ingrained it inside of his
subconscious mind which is causing him
to project the melodies and the songs
and over and over and over so if you can
understand the process of how that works
I like to speak in things and
relatability terms where people actually
understand you can understand the
process of how it works when you listen
to a song over and over and over
now imagine listen to the song called
I'm broke I'm broke I'm broke I'm broke
I'm broke I'm broke or a kill still
drugs or insecure or the voice inside
listening to that over and over and over
I'm ugly I'm ugly I'm ugly I'm insecure
I'm not worthy I'm not worthy well if
you're ten years old five years old
twenty years old thirty years old that's
like listening to listen to this broken
record every day all day long so what do
you think your life is going to look
like your life is gonna look exactly
like the story you keep telling yourself
on the inside so what you would need to
do or what you get to do is listen to
and empowering a more empowering
narrative so maybe on positive thinking
maybe on gratitude may be on selfless
service maybe on love and listening to
that I turned off the TV I turned off
the radio and I made all of that time
there's four hours a day and I turned
all of that time into my University on
wheels so like when I was in my car I
would just listen to I was listening to
like the power of positive thinking by
Norman Vincent Peale the power by Rhonda
Byron's Eric Thomas Tony Robbins Jim
Road and I was just listening over and
over and over overriding 30 years of
thinking one way you've got to do it
over and over and over and over and over
when the tipping scale starts going to
what you're constantly listening to your
life will crack the code so our mind is
like a big cement block
because of what we were grained as a
child and ingrained as a child if you
drop the seat on that cement block
nothing happens but what's under cement
dirt and soil so we take that drill if
you drill one time nothing happens but
when you drill over and over something
that opens up the seed drops in goes
into the soil finally something can grow
so listening to something over and over
and over and over riding your old
thought process your old paradigm till
something cracks that is one thing that
you can apply today but it can't be I'm
kind of doing this I'm I want to be
successful so I'm gonna kind of do this
and kind of do that because you'll get a
kind of result you must jump into it
with abandon like a baby learning how to
walk like somebody learning how to ride
a bike like the same way that you did
learning the ABCs it's all part of the
same philosophy you just got to commit
yourself to mastery and in the area in
in the arena of something that you
actually want how do you make it
important enough for people to drill
through the cement block to get to the
dirt people really just don't know the
payoff of their life so if you could if
you could really see the scope of your
life of the last 15 years if it's the
same the same the same the same the same
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
same bank account the same I still date
the same kind of people and the same the
same the same the same the same and what
you're realizing is people don't do what
you say they do what they see so if you
got children
you're literally teaching them how to
operate below average with below average
thinking and if you're insecure if
you're not doing anything if you're not
jumping into your life and jumping into
success or jumping into abundance with
abandon what's happening is you're
teaching everyone around you how to be
exactly how you are and people again
people don't do what you say
they do what they see and they respond
to how they feel so you can be saying
something I stood on stage in front of
30,000 people and I said everybody touch
your nose touch your nose touch your
nose
and 95% of the room touch their forehead
because they were watching what I was
doing
sir our children our students the
society when we make our music videos
we're literally teaching the next
generation how to be us when you just
literally turn on the TV and you see
what's going on what's going on is a
bunch of people that don't love
themselves who don't know themselves who
haven't woken up to the power that
exists inside of them to generate
natural-born happiness and from there
people really don't see the payoff of
just existing in life until they're
aware of it that's what happened to me I
just carried on with the same life
saying like try to change everything up
top which is like you know melting ice
on a mud pie like it's like icing on a
mud pie just over and over and over
nothing is going to change if you're
trying to change from the surface but it
wasn't until I got to the root of
everything the root of my childhood on
how everything started where rejection
started where insecurity started where
fear started confronted it cleared the
space and created a whole new
possibility to live in - for my future
when I was aware of the damage that I
was doing to everyone around me and my
child
and my future and my legacy that's when
I was like hope I didn't realize that
I'm calling causing my life but I had no
idea
so somebody showed me this is what your
life is gonna look like if you carry on
because all my friends that I grew up
with dead like my best friends they're
dead and we were all doing the same
thing but I I chose to make the left
instead of making a right you know so
getting people to see the payoff of the
what's going on in their life and how
you're showing up and what it what it's
causing to your bank account the fact
that you have like
no one like you don't feel loved you
feel alone you feel insecure and all of
that stuff we're doing that to ourselves
but if you don't know that you're doing
that to yourselves then the blame is
going out first taking full
responsibility and knowing like wow I
can't change anyone else but I can
change myself now start learning more
about yourself that's what it is it's
like seeing the payoff of what you're
doing to your own life and it's you
causing your life so I know you had the
moment in the car that was like
life-changing for you you had to change
your whole direction do you think people
have to go and hit rock bottom to make
the big change is it required absolutely
not
I learned the hard way it is not
required from 2003 to 2005 I was 2 and a
half years in prison two and a half
years living in my car so funny is like
two and a half years everything's two
and a half years I earned a seven-figure
income too once I started to figure it
out figure it out but two and a half
years in a French prison two and a half
years living in my car and then a ten
year stretch where I was going from
couch to couch to couch to girls house
to couch and try to figure out my damn
life but it's so funny because I'll
speak to people they're like ah you know
it's I'm so glad I didn't have to go to
prison and I'm like so how's your
relationship with that guy that you've
been dating for five years and you know
damn well you don't want to be in that
relationship guess what you're in prison
right now how about that 10-year job
that paid you less than your value and
you're only staying because of benefits
but you're stressing out to go to the
doctor from the job that's causing you
to have stress like that's prison if
you're not doing what you love so we all
pretty much go grow through the same
things internally or mentally and just
on the surface it looks different like
you don't have to hit the rock bottom I
would say to learn quicker so if there's
people who's actually grown through a
life that's willing to give the
information listen listen
don't listen and try to turn it into
your own way because if you're not happy
and then you try to do things your own
way that's like a fifth grader trying to
teach himself how to get out of fifth
grade which I've never seen that in a
million years it's always classroom
facilitator the teacher that can teach
you how to develop the skills to pass
the test to go to the next level for me
I just say if you see somebody who
inspires you a great deal success leaves
clues and so watch out the meant that
the person shakes hand I learned this
from Jim Rohn watch how he walks watch
how he speaks about people watch how
people respond to him and if it's
something that you're not doing Chauncey
Maxwell says successful people are
willing to do the things that
unsuccessful people won't do I was
living a horrible life and I was
complaining and saying oh that person is
lucky that person had a silver spoon oh
no I was just lazy and I wasn't willing
to pick up the success tips that they
were showing by observation every single
day i'ma show y'all I got this really
cool room real quick and it's got all
these inspirational people all over the
wall with nice boots
you got Pharrell Barack Conor McGregor
you got Martin Luther King Nelson
Mandela Albert I nice holder you here's
my inspiration room I love it I love it
is I procrastinate and I want to make
sure I'm surrounded by people who done
big things in the world and they inspire
me to not procrastinate it's awesome you
got you got all these inspirational
people on I mean I got I got my own wall
of Heroes here that I walk into how
important is is a physical environment
to help you get your mind set right I
always speak in terms of language so say
for instance you learn the ABCs and
whatever whatever country you're in or
whatever language they speak but
whatever environment that you
and the way that the people are speaking
that's what language you're gonna speak
so if you were born in America like
you're your first language is English if
you were born in America you were born
somewhere else he was born and born in
China your first language is going to be
Chinese so I think in terms of that but
if I hadn't been into that kinda in the
culture and the accountability in the
environments then I wouldn't have
learned English that that because that's
all that I saw so when I think of terms
of language you think broke you think
insecurity you think doubtful think all
these different things that is a form of
language so whatever your environment
you grew up around if your mom was
saying we ain't got no money your dad
was saying we broke we broke we broke we
can't afford it we can't afford it we
ain't got no money we ain't got no money
we ain't got no money I promise you you
will not have the keys to success
growing up unless you learn differently
that's your form of ABCs called broke
that manifested as you get older will
turn into somebody that will go to their
grave with less than $20 an event and in
the bank account which like I think it's
some crazy number like 85% of people on
the planet die go to their grave with
less than 20 dollars in their bank
account the environment is so important
because we have an energetic body around
us and it's very far that's why you can
be in a room full of people who don't
like you and you can feel it in your
soul you can be in a room full of people
who love you like family and grandmother
cooking and you can feel it in your soul
without anybody saying a word
that's all environment so if you want to
learn the language you don't go to
Starbucks listen to the rosetta stone
once a week you want to learn French go
to France be amongst the people listen
like have a baguette eat the food you
will learn the language ten times more
just because of the the culture effect
flowers that grow together grow much
faster together than they do by
themselves but it's the same way of
learning
so if you're around a bunch of people
who are speaking about visions and goals
and aspirations and they're up to
something
and they're action-oriented people I
promise you that's going to expedite
your results but if you're around
negative cynical people they're
complaining about traffic complaining
about themselves and saying all of these
negative things you might as well tie in
a two-ton elephant on your legs and
never fly to your dreams never get out
and if you're the one causing it erase
all of that negativity from who your
being because you're the one that's
generating all of this negative stuff
nothing negative
nothing resentful nothing hateful you
you will not find prosperity and and
grace and love and an abundance inside
of that you'll find the exact opposite
somebody asked what are you what if you
have a negative family do you have to be
around them 24/7
I grew up around people that were very
negative but guess what
I was always reading to imagine it like
looking at him imaginary movies and
being around and looking at the stars on
my own and coloring running and doing
things that I absolutely loved so it's
not you know it you can have the
negative family but you don't have to be
around them you can choose to be around
them or you can choose to be the person
that creates a new way of being inside
of your family and at least the next
generation has a chance but if you stay
inside of that you're going to
contribute to the next generation being
just as negative as your family is for
some people who this is their first
exposure to you they haven't heard you
before they're learning about the man
Karen Jones like what is what is the
message that you want to tell a
first-time person who's just stumbling
upon you right now learn as much about
yourself as you can and what I mean by
that is we came over to this life
and we were just handed whatever tools
we were handed if you're born into a
Muslim family you're Muslim unless you
choose different if you're born into a
Christian family you're Christian and
you didn't choose any of those things
you were born into it
your mom fed you chicken your mom fed
you tofu and you just kind of just took
this on my biggest piece of advice is to
find out so much about yourself and also
find out why you do the things that you
do if you don't know why you do the
things that you do you will be a slave
to your mental environment and you will
never be free no matter how much you say
the word freedom because if you have a
bunch of things that you do every single
day and it was like I don't know because
my mom does it I don't know because my
and then I'll tell you listen my mom she
cuts the end off the the bread of my mom
why'd he cut the end off the bridge I
don't know because my mom doesn't ask my
grandmother why'd you cut the end off
the bread I don't know because my mom
did ask my great-grandmother before she
passed away at 104 why do you cut the
end off the bridge he's like because the
toasters too small so I went back three
generations to find out with two
generations had no idea and that was
about bread now what about your life so
when I was in self-discovery and
learning more about myself I'm like mom
why do I eat chicken she was like
because that's what I fed you I didn't
get to choose it I only eat fish now but
I chose that when I was 13 years old I
was forced to eat fish and I didn't want
to have anything in my life where I
didn't choose it because I want to be
free like my ultimate goal is to go to
sleep at night and it's peaceful and
it's calm free of fear free of doubt
free of worry I don't know I don't like
I don't owe anybody money like it in its
calm that's my that's my definition of
success well so while I was in my
self-discovery there was lots of things
that I didn't even know like I used to
be a hoarder now I'm like super
clean but I came from a family of
Hoarders so that was ingrained inside of
me being broke was ingrained inside of
me being so insecure was ingrained
inside of me like others so many
different things but I didn't choose it
it was by nature and so I had once I
realized that I could learn more about
myself and why I do the things that I do
that's when I started going to seminars
that's when I started releasing
resentment like at men I forgave the two
men who murdered my father and set them
free but in setting them free I also set
myself free I made a list of 250 names
then I apologized to anybody that ever
done any negativity - and I also forgave
myself in the process that was freedom
inside of them you create the space to
make room for your blessings so inside
of my self discovery I started I was
like oh why do I feel light and every
time I was releasing and releasing and
releasing released the weight the weight
of resentment the weight of hate the
weight of insecurity the weight of doubt
the weight of fear so on the other side
of all of those things is the door to
more so and this is coming from somebody
who only six to six and a half years ago
was $200,000 in debt living in his car
for two and a half years wanting to kill
myself as a black man in America who did
not have a relationship with his
daughter who now is madly in love with
his daughter got his daughter back now I
had several multi seven-figure income
businesses in love with all of my family
really worked those relationships and
teaching leadership and speaking on
stages all over the world and it's
happening effortlessly I worked really
hard on the mind so that everything else
can flow according the nature I'm not
speaking on though I don't know there's
a lot of people in them this guy is
speaking you have no idea what you're
talking about I only speak what I've
actually lived
I don't speak what I read in a book but
I learned from the seminar all
those are confirmation of how I live my
life every single day so anybody got
anything from this I promise you
anything that you applied from this
right here just one degree more will
drastically change into the trajectory
of your life thank you for sharing your
message man Garen Jones the mindset King
listen for people who want to dive
deeper into your world what's the best
next spot for them well I have a book
coming out might change your mindset
change a life book oh my goodness gonna
be crazy it's scheduled to come out in
three months okay and it's really cool
because I hi I took 2,000 index cards
and I went up to a bunch of random
strangers and I and I asked like if you
could ask the world three questions in
able and it would answer to change your
life what would you ask and I took the
questions that was asked the most and if
I lived those questions and had a result
I knew I could answer the world's
question the book is in everyday
people's guide to understanding the
power that lives inside of you how to
access it generate it and drive
incredible results through your life and
then you can check me out on Instagram
of course my website Garen Jones calm my
facebook Garen Jones and definitely send
me a note if you've got any value from
this please send me a DM or something
and and share by the way last thing I'm
gonna leave you with if you have the
overload of unused information stored in
your brain start to spill over into the
physical evidence in your life go on a
cleaning spree right now throw out all
your dirty drawers and panties underwear
if there's over six months renew
yourself get some new ones
get some new socks get your old ass
dusty broom that's like this get a new
broom and and literally upgrade yourself
all those clothes that's just been
sitting there you like to hum I wear it
one day get rid of it get it to somebody
else and literally create the space and
when you do that there's a special gift
waiting for when you actually create the
space you guys I love it so much
positivity thank you so much Gary
enforcement at a time man really
appreciate it and
looking forward to the book launch
absolutely and thank you so much for
your support the work that you're doing
in the world always raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
we believe that people with passion and
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's something sue me if you want
more Garin Jones check out the top 10
video we did on him the link is right
there next to me I think you're gonna
enjoy continue to believe and I'll see
you there
I remember lying down in the middle of
the road and I'm like I wanna die like
right now